started i'm joined by rob handlery hi
butterworth below hello boys you played
a lot of the division lately right yeah
a lot yeah I think we're obviously a
little more than me but yeah it's been
since yesterday morning just been like
division time go so yes unlike most
games we did not get this early yeah so
you guys are playing like the real deal
retail servers at launch yeah correct
how has that been so far I know some
games like Street Fighter had some
problems with their servers but the
division seems to be going pretty well
yeah I mean nothing compared to the
problem Street Fighter had for sure yeah
I mean you hear like issues like a
little bit like for me like I've been
fine I've been completely fine as far as
joining up and playing with other people
saying a breeze but you know once a
while like I play with Eric day
yesterday for a very long marathon would
you can check out on video games duck
I'm just right he unfortunately had a
couple crashes no big deal and that's
all on reddit this morning there was an
issue I don't know if it was just for PC
but it was a photo of this huge line for
like one of the first missions and no
one was able to like basically hold f oh
yeah so it in the game starts everyone
has to go to the same shared safe room
and in that room there is one laptop
that you have to like walk up to and hit
a button prompt to initiate a certain
mission so you have a room full of like
actual live human players who all need
to use the same laptop and apparently
rooms have been so populated that people
can't physically move their character to
the laptop to engage the prom that
sounds ridiculous it's literally a line
it's the funniest image it's like two
dozen people just in a line one laptop
it's so funny that everyone would like
even line up to do that thankfully I
think Rob and I both avoided that
problem and we haven't seen anything
that stupid since then there have been
other smaller issues but that's like
just kind of a funny situation but you
guys have gotten into the game and
plated a bunch so I'm really curious I'm
assuming you both had some experience
with the beta how are things change
since then it was only a couple weeks
ago but now we have the whole game like
what's what's new how do things feel any
different the only concerns I had were
like just quantity all around like uh
you know more npcs more AI at about
the dark zone all of that for the most
part has been fixed if not surprising
how alive this huge new york city is
like for me and like as a recap of how i
feel i'm like having a really great time
with this game i mean i haven't
necessarily been just utterly blown away
by the world but certainly there's a lot
more going on and it feels more alive
than it did in the beta's i definitely
agree with that it's really cool to be
wandering around you hear somebody say
something nearby but yeah what's like
where did that come from and you look up
and you see people are actually like in
the buildings that are you're walking
underneath just kind of a cool touch you
notice things like that as you wander
around and you know I haven't seen too
many like reused assets or anything they
did a pretty good job of making streets
feel kind of unique so far everything
I've seen has just been you know exactly
what you expect it's an urban
environment and ruin and their cars
strewn about but you know within that
context they've they've done a pretty
good job of making the environments feel
diverse and like you're saying a little
more live so I'm curious because this is
a sort of a dark story you know the
cinema is under horrible disease like
the society itself has sort of changed
as a result Rob you were telling me
about some really dark stuff that isn't
this game and where'd you can share some
of that yeah so many elements of just
like you take a step back and go wow
this is like they're not holding
anything back and telling this really
dark story which I am no one really
knows it's basically you know Black
Friday terrorists have devised a
successful form of smallpox embedded in
all the paper currency in New York City
and everyone's got smallpox and
everyone's dying so you're constantly
just walking around the city just body
bags or like one missions a huge
incinerator well they're just throwing
bodies into a pit it's like dark there's
literally a waterfall of bodies and bags
it's like pouring into a pit of fire
okay cool yeah and with that in mind it
is a very grounded story in that you
know it's not too far in the future it's
like you know this could happen right
it's a Tom Clancy thriller this could
happen and you're constantly reminded of
like you know these factions you know
some people want to just basically burn
everything or some people want to take
advantage
of this uprising and and you know go
rogue and you know take on the
government yeah there are these you know
they have collectibles with little
cinematics one of them being like this
scene where it's a it's a girl on a cell
phone so you get like a cell phone video
and she's you know in a room and they're
these guys called cleaners and they come
in and they got flame throwers and they
just torch everything and she's hiding
from them and she's you know in like a
like a market so she's looking through
cracks and she's you think she's okay
and then gustl snow and wind goes right
past the camera meaning there's someone
behind her and she opens up into the
flamethrower guy is there looking at her
almost reminds me of pyro from like team
fortress or he's like looking at her and
[ __ ] his head just because he has a
flamethrower he's really dark and then
he kills her and she's screaming so
that's and then you hear audio of her
screaming and being burned alive and
that type of stuff happens all the time
yeah most of that kind of content is
comes from like the collectibles story
is clearly not the focus of the division
it's you know you're not getting a cut
scene every couple steps or anything
like that this is not Hideo Kojima game
but if you're looking for collectibles
you can absolutely find like cell phone
videos or audio recordings things like
that and those tend to be both the
darkest and you know do the most to kind
of flesh out the world i mean there's
another one you found that I that I also
found pretty early on of like it's a
bunch of security camera footage of two
guys running from a bunch of looters and
it's like pretty harrowing watching them
like trip over themselves and of course
they like run into a gate and can't get
past and get caught and just like
basically beaten to death and you know
tastefully cuts away before it shows any
real gore or anything but it's you know
obviously implied that they're being
brutally murdered yeah and like it's
yeah it's pretty unflinching but at the
same time there are moments where you
kind of have to ignore the world that
this game is set in in a weird way like
I mean the most basic most obviously you
can point to you is the fact that it
just takes a long time to kill anybody
dudes and hoodies and jackets can
withstand like three or four head shots
before they die so goodies then I can't
apparently and I mean like that's a
widely known thing and you know people
who like to defend the game will always
point out that all it's an RPG in our
shooter but it's still just ematic alee
as odd to be shooting app Uman and then
watch them just like completely shrug
off bullets and like barely even react
and stuff like that and i also have a
bit of a hard time
getting past the fact that you know
you're this sort of peacekeeping unit
and your job is to kind of clean up and
you know restore order in the city but
literally the only what you do that is
just like wander around killing people
but you will just see looters in the
street who like are not engaging you who
are not threatening but because they're
that particular character model you know
that they are like the looter enemy
class and you know that as soon as they
notice you they're going to shoot you so
even if they haven't done anything York
job as the gamers like well I gotta kill
him because if I don't they're gonna
shoot me and so this is weird thematic
disconnect of like you kind of have to
ignore the world that you're in to make
it all make sense you know that's a
beautiful segue into a question from
syrup lantus in the chat why don't
people slip over in the snow this should
good at it I mean so the agents were all
there embedded in like their active in
New York whose they were living in New
York art so they're seasoned pros they
know what they're doing they know how to
have that like gingerly walk yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah my step don'ts shuffle my
trendy mountain boots are doing just
yeah click boots Saudi great great game
for foods just mention one thing though
yeah I agree if you like you know you
just see the looters and yes if you
don't engage they will I'm sorry if you
just approach them they're gonna gauge
you however um you know on the flip side
you'll you'll turn a corner and you'll
see a looter hovering over a distressed
you know civilian who's standing there
in satin this happens couple times but
it's a really interesting thing work
she's got a bat and he's saying like
you're worthless like what are you gonna
do about it if you don't kill him before
he basically takes this woman down beats
her and then if you didn't engage he's
just gonna continually beat her dead
body it's like you're witnessing this
and I think I've had that happen like
three or four times and I've only been
able to shoot him like twice before he
kills her it's like there's still a hero
element of you you know you have a good
heart and you're going around trying to
prevent the wrongdoings but it's just
like really again like this dark
scenarios that make you take a step back
and kind of think like this is kind of
surreal but like surprisingly real like
I don't know like riders in the state of
apocalypse like this is what would
happen
and I like that idea of being reminded
like how awful humanity can can kind of
unfold and these scenarios are no it's
just yes I think the game to actually it
really goes out of its way to sort of
justify your actions whenever it can but
it still feels weird that you're just a
total judge dredd type like judge jury
executioner like anyone you see like
death sentence pressure you're behaving
badly death it's just like okay it would
have been nice if there have been a
little more nuanced but but I agree it's
not you know I don't feel like you know
a horrible human by playing this game or
anything like right it's just like there
are certain moments where the themes
kind of fall apart or come into conflict
with the way that the game actually
plays yeah I mean it's nothing in the
world is just something I've notices
they've been playing yeah and we've got
your early impressions up on the site
right now yeah yeah I mean we always
like to just throw up a page let people
know like no we're reviewing the game
but this is what we don't have a review
the day the game comes up goes up
because we often do so yeah people can
go find my early impressions they can
watch the livestream that Robin Eric
recorded yesterday that's all up there
so plenty of stuff for people to check
out even we don't have a skort review
and get a good sense of like what to
expect from the game maybe we'll find
out more later oh there's so much more
to talk about to their all the the perks
and cover system like you could easily
talk about the game for an entire hour
so and yeah we did live stream yesterday
but uh having the game before its
release you know the dark zone like
that's still up in the air there we we
did toward the end the stream get in
there in Eric hey did backstab me a few
times just to kind of show what may be
the potential rogue life is but there
weren't really many people playing so
it's hard to tell what that is even
going to be about for the people who
haven't been playing the dark zones are
like the PvP areas in the world that you
like consciously enter and then it
becomes this kind of free for all you
can sort of join out with people or not
or you can betray them or take looter
it's this whole crazy thing it seems
like maybe one of the most interesting
mechanical aspects of the game but as
Rob pointed out it's requires a bit of a
higher level so we'll get there we
haven't had a chance to really explore
it yet okay one last question before we
go out Jeffrey sparks wants to know our
collectibles from the dark zone actually
worth it or just reskin or different
perks I don't know what he's talking
about this I saw them play the division
but it's hard to tell ah the beta like
pushing aside the beta I would imagine
the idea of or the incentive to go into
dark zone is to get higher valued loot
at the moment differing from the beta
was likee that you do missions you do
side missions you the the payoff as far
as Lukos is is alright it's like
substantial but in my opinion the idea
of the dark zone is is to go for those
higher and those purple weapons you know
the better stuff at the moment it's hard
to tell but yeah it seems like it would
kind of have to be I feel like that's
almost the part of the design of the
dark zone but again we haven't actually
spent that much time in the now finished
retail version of the dark soon we most
of our experience was in betas and I
feel like it you know it was worthwhile
in the betas I found you know the best
stuff that I come across all in the dark
zone so I would assume that will be true
in the retail version as well but hard
to confirm I mean like it's there is an
obvious added challenge and just getting
stuff out of the dark zone so it would
only make sense for the developers to
incentivize that gameplay in some way
yeah so it would be kind of insane if
those items weren't better but we'll see
all right now thank you Scott Raab
talking about the division hmm we will
be playing more of the division before a
review goes live later this week have
you been playing are you waiting in line
to press f on that laptop let us know in
the comments
you